broossooli he morning host on 105.7 his
own fox affiliate in Columbus Ohio the
show that precedes this show and kind
enough to join us Bruce good morning how
are you I'm good dan I'm gonna need a
shower shame if we get any more in the
muck here on the Ohio Urban Meyer story
way but it's quiet all quiet or is it
quiet Oh Dan you've not been on Facebook
over the weekend there all kinds of
allegations flying yeah I saw some of
that all right can we separate fact from
fiction here on some of these Facebook
reports we can separate that Tom Herman
of the Texas coach has admitted that he
and his wife Michelle loaned some money
or gave money to Courtney Smith the
ex-wife of the fired Ohio State wide
receivers coach for her legal bills
where that sits on the continuum Dan of
being a compassionate gesture for a
woman in trouble or at the other end
being a duplicitous act of a coach
engaged in nefarious negative recruiting
is up to whether you decide that you
know Tom Herman is a saint or the
ultimate sinner betraying his former
boss Urban Meyer when is Zach Smith
going to be the former coach be
interviewed by this committee deciding
on Urban Meyer's fate I am told that
will happen today or tomorrow they were
interviewing administrative and former
administrative people on Thursday and
Friday of last week and the
characterization I got of the
committee's questions is that it's not a
whitewash that it is a legitimate
fact-finding effort and I think a lot of
people wondered about that when Ohio
State said that the investigation would
take 14 days before it ever really got
started but those who have been in the
room say that it's no joke which you'd
expect with Mary Jo white being the
hired investigator of this and she's
been in on the Jerry Richardson bang the
Ezekiel Elliott thing with the NFL so
she's got investigative chops and that's
the person in charge of all this might
surprise you with the question I don't
know but it feels like that Jean Smith
it feel that there
more pressure on the athletic director
than the head coach do you believe that
well that's I do believe there's
pressure on him he's on vacation this
week you can make of that whatever you
want here make a lot of jokes about it
because Jeanne is never on the record on
anything so you know Jeanne Smith's on
vacation how do you know those jokes are
involved in vogue in Columbus this week
I think Dan I've covered Ohio State for
30 years and I'm guessing here so it's
it's an educated guess but it's a guess
I think they're trying to figure out how
they can position this at the end so
they minimize or eliminate their legal
culpability and still try to look good
and the way that I keep landing on is
that they will position it at the end
that they did everything right from an
administrative viewpoint and from an
Urban Meyer viewpoint but that Ohio
State aspires to do more than the
minimums and so there will be some
sanctions on both sides on the
administrative side and on the coaching
side I can't imagine they'll keep Urban
Meyer off the field and away from his
team and then come out with no
suspension at all and I'm not saying
that's justified I'm not saying I
advocate for that I'm saying this is my
guest based upon assorted scandals at
Ohio State through the years and this
kind of push-pull between the
administrative academic side and the
athletic side are there any local leaks
feels like this is more national than it
gets out than local well there's an
interesting dynamic in Columbus that has
changed in the last couple of years dan
and that is the sale of the newspaper in
town which used to be owned by a very
powerful individual who also owned the
radio station that has Ohio State's
rights and the dominant television
station in the market and everything
else always used to be filtered through
those three entities host now that that
individual has passed away I'm not sure
that that same sort of homage is paid by
the powers that be at Ohio State so
perhaps we're seeing a new era where
everybody is on a level playing field in
terms of breaking news or perhaps not
perhaps one of those two entities now
the radio station or the television
station we'll get this first and maybe
if they get it first they've worked hard
and just
and I don't say that they didn't but
that's typically how things have worked
in the past and the timeframe for a
decision is at this point next week I
think if you count the days forward from
when they announced the committee we
could go Sunday we are on day eight and
they said day you know 14 days or less
so it could be Friday it's the thing is
made for a Friday afternoon news Bruce
will be talking to you soon thanks for
joining us
okay Dan thank you that's broossooli
does a great job morning host 105.7 to
zone fox affiliate in Columbus for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]